a Las Vegas mother on a mission to find
her daughter now her pleas for help have
gone viral on Tick Tock and the mother
sharing her daughter's story with eight
news now investigator Vanessa Murphy
Vanessa here with more on what's now
become an FBI missing persons case
yeah Brian I talked with the mother of
zaly Flores she says she received a call
that her daughter was being held for
ransom in Mexico the demand 500 she says
she doesn't know what to believe here
she just wants to know her daughter is
safe and now the FBI is involved now
here's the missing persons poster for 21
year old zaly Flores her mother says she
last spoke with her daughter on January
12th that's 19 days ago her daughter
sounded incoherent and she said she was
in Mexico than a series of events
followed including that possible Ransom
call communication with an older man
whose story she says doesn't add up the
mother then turning to Tick-Tock and law
enforcement to ask for help to find her
child
daily
[Music]
um
I don't know where you're at but I'm
gonna keep looking
and um
if you are okay and you can call me call
because
I just want to know you're okay
April Reed says her daughter has had
struggles with mental health and drug
abuse but I think this is a story a lot
of parents can relate to Brian this is a
mother who just wants to make sure her
child is safe and again the FBI is
involved